فان فرنسا والمانيا كقرا للاتحاد الاوروبي
تريدان همم تكريس التحالف وتوثيق التعاون
الاقتصادي ولكن ايضا
فللعب دور مستقل ااا نسبيا عن الولايات
المتحده وبالطبع مواجه لاراده التوسع
الروسي
سياسيني اقتصاديا
النظر الفرنسيه تجاهها اوروبا على انها
قاره مدموجه بشكل اكبر وان تكون مستقله
بشكل اكبر عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هذه الرؤيا لا تتشاركها المانيا كثيرا
خصوصا بعد الاشتياح الروسي اوكرانيا
المانيا تود ان ترى اوروبا قويه وهي على
جاهزيه لصرف الاموال على الميزانيه
الدفاعيه لتحقيقه هذا الهدف ولكن تود ان
يبقى الاتحاد الاوروبي شريكا وحريفا وثيقه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
بعد رئاسه دونالد ترامب وبدء الانتفاء
الامريكي وكلام ترامب عن الناتو وعن ضروره
التراجع الولايات المتحده عن تمويله بعد
الاوروبيون وقروش بريطانيا ايضا بدل
الاوروبيون في القاره يعتبرون ان الامور
تتغير ثم جاءت حرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
لتؤكد هذا التغير قد يكون هناك مشاكل في
شمال افريقيا في الشرق الاوسط في البلقان
والولايات المتحده قد تقرر لانها لا تود
ان تشارك هذا يعني نعم ان اوروبا يجب ان
تستعد لكي تكون مستقله بشكل
فرنسا فرنسا تضع موازنه للسنوات المقبله
من 400 مليار يورو تقريبا لتطوير
الصناعتها العسكريه المانيا ايضا بدات
بوضع موازنات جديده ايطاليا تلعب دورا في
هذا الاتجاه اضافه الى هولندا ودول اخرى
اعتقد ان الامور تواجه بمعارضه داخليه في
اكثر من دوله اوروبيه لا تريد للموازنات
العسكريه ان تتضخم كثيرا اوروبا مثلا لم
يكن لديها مخازن كافيه للسخائر الان هناك
كلام عن اعاده استملاك المؤسسات او مصانع
لتخليل اسلحه همم هناك مشكله لوجديه
موجوده يحاول الاوروبيون التعامل معها من
دون ان يكون فقط شراء الاسلحه من الولايات
المتحده هو الاسلوب الناجح هذه الامور
اضافه الى مساء الاقتصاديه واخرى ترتبط
بالحدود
والنخور بين بعض الدول او التنافس على
القياده بين بعض الدول لا شيء وفي الغرب
كل هذه الامور برايسه بطئ نسبيا ايضا على
الاستقلال الاوروبي وامريكا تبقى بالنسبه
للعواصم الاوروبيه الضمان العسكريه الاولى
[موسيقى]
بنسبه الى المسائل المرتبطه بالموقف
الاوروبي المساله الاساسيه هي انهم لا
يعرفون اين تتجه الولايات المتحده لا
يعرفون من هو الرئيس الجديد في الولايات
المتحده ما هي السياسه الخارجيه
المستقبليه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لذلك اوروبا تستثمر في قدراتها الخاصه
موقف الامريكي يقضي بضروره بناء القدرات
وان تصبح اوروبا اقوى وسوف نصل الى كيفيه
استخدام هذه القوه نحن نفضل الشراكه
العابره للاطلسي ولكننا نفهم انه في بعض
الحالات قد يتطلب الموقف ان تتصرف اوروبا
لوحدها والان هو الوقت كي تتجهز اوروبا
لذلك فهل هناك تنافس بالضبط بالتاكيد
بنسبه الى التكنولوجيا والشركات الكبرى
وهناك مناقشات مرتبطه بالقانون القاضي الى
خفض التضخم الى اخره ولكن لا اعتقد ان هذه
الامور يمكنها باي شكل من اشكال ان تقود
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه قلق الاساسيه هو ان
اوروبا لا تؤدي بشكل جيد
[موسيقى]
ربي همم بات محدودا في بعض الامكنه وفي
اسرائيل بالتحديد مع وجود اليمين واليمين
المتطرف ومع سيادته التي لا يريد اي
مساومه في في عنفها وفي
اعتدائها على الفلسطينيين لا اعتقد ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي له وزن كبير